>> ONLY A SUCKER WOULDN'T LIKE
TUCKER.
TUCKER CARLSON'S BRAND-NEW BOOK
IS OUT TODAY ON THE STATE OF THE
MEDIA IT'S CALLED THE LONG
SLIDE, 30 YEARS AND AMERICAN
JOURNALISM.
YOU CAN GET IT IN PERSON WERE
BOOKS ARE SOLD.
OR BUY IT ON TUCKER CARLSON.COM.
HI, TUCKER, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> COULDN'T BE BETTER, GREG
GUTFELD.
>> I WAS ALWAYS A FAN OF YOUR
WRITING BEFORE I EVEN KNEW YOU
AND ONE THING I LEARNED FROM YOU
ONCE IS THAT YOU DON'T LIKE TO
WRITE.
KICK IT NOBODY LIKES TO WRITE.
YOU HAVE TO BE DEFECTIVE TO LIKE
TO WRITE.
TO CREATE SOMETHING OUT OF
NOTHING AND BLINK TERMINAL, AS
YOU KNOW, YOU STARTED AS A
WRITER TO, ITS DEEPLY REWARDING,
I'M GLAD IT'S DONE, I DON'T WANT
TO DO TOO MUCH MORE IF I CAN
HELP IT, BUT THESE ARE ESSAYS
THAT HAVE BEEN REFINED AND
EVERYTHING, SO ASIDE FROM THE
LONG INTRODUCTION IN WHICH YOU
MENTION HOW MUCH YOU LIKE AL
SHARPTON, THESE ARE ALL OLDER
STORIES, CORRECT?
>> IS, BUT THEY ARE FRAMED BY A
REPORTED PIECE I DID, WHICH IS
THE BEGINNING OF THE BOOK ON
SIMON & SCHUSTER WHICH PUBLISHED
IT WHICH IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PUBLISHERS IN THE WORLD AND THE
LONG DEFENDER OF THEIR FREEDOM
OF SPEECH, THE FREE FLOW OF
IDEAS, DISSENT, THE ABILITY TO
DISAGREE WHICH HAS BECOME ONE OF
THE LEADING FORCES OF CENSORSHIP
IN THE COUNTRY, KILLING BOOKS
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DOESN'T LIKE THE BOOK SO TO
WRITE THE INTRODUCTION, TO WRITE
THIS CHAPTER I INTERVIEWED THE
HEAD OF THE COMPANY AND THE NEW
HEAD OF WHO WAS HIRED AFTER THE
GEORGE FLOYD RIOTS, BUT
LITERALLY NOT ONE DAY OF
EXPERIENCE IN THE PUBLISHING
BUSINESS.
I ASKED THEM, ONE WAY JUST LIKE
IT ONE OF THE BIGGEST PUBLISHERS
IN THE WORLD, HOW DID YOU GET TO
BE CENSORED, HOW DID THIS
HAPPEN?
I THOUGHT THEY WERE PRETTY
HONEST ABOUT THEIR ROLE IN IT.
IT WAS NAUSEATING IF I'M GOING
TO BE TOTALLY BLUNT WITH YOU,
BUT IT WAS CERTAINLY
INFORMATIVE.
KK SO, TUCKER, I FIRST CAME TO
KNOW YOU WHEN YOU ARE WRITING
MAGAZINE PIECES IN THE LATE
90s,.
>> AND I LOVED READING YOUR
WORK, AND I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
THE REPORTING PART OF IT AND
INTERVIEWING AND GETTING TO KNOW
PEOPLE IS ALSO A REALLY
IMPORTANT THING, BUT I STILL
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO LEARN HOW TO
WRITE.
WHAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
PEOPLE CAN DO IF YOUR YOUNG
PERSON AND YOU WANT TO BE A
WRITER AND YOU WANT TO BE LIKE
TUCKER CARLSON, HOW DO YOU GET
THOSE SKILLS, WHAT IS THE BEST
WAY TO LEARN HOW TO WRITE?
>> THEIR AREN'T A LOT OF SKILLS,
IT'S THE TRADE, NOT A
PROFESSION.
DON'T GO TO JOURNALISM SCHOOL,
THEY WILL MAKE YOU DUMBER.
LEARN HOW TO WRITE CLEAR
ENGLISH.
WE HAVE THE BIGGEST LANGUAGE IN
HUMAN HISTORY.
YOU HAVE ALL THE WORDS COME OUT
LEARN HOW TO USE THEM, USE
GRAMMAR, AND HAVE A DECLARATIVE
SENTENCE.
TAKE OUT THE ADJECTIVES.
ADVERBS ARE YOUR ENEMY, AVOID
THEM.
JUST LEARN TO WRITE CLEARLY.
THAT'S THE WHOLE TRICK RIGHT
THERE IT'S NOT HARD AT ALL.
>> DO YOU MISS THOSE PIECES AT
ALL?
>> I WRITE EVERY DAY, RIGHT NOW
MORE THAN I'VE EVER WRITTEN IN
MY LIFE, BUT I DON'T GET OUT OF
MY WEIRD LITTLE CAVE TO TALK TO
OTHER PEOPLE, AND I DEFINITELY
MISS GETTING ON THE ROAD TWO
FARAWAY PLACES.
>> I DIDN'T MEAN TO MONOPOLIZE
YOUR TIME.
>> WELL, I'M GOING TO ASK A
REALLY LONG QUESTION NOW.
A LITTLE LIKE YOU, I SPENT A LOT
OF TIME WHAT WOULD YOU CALL THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
I'M FASCINATED OF THE IDEA OF
THE LONG SLIDE, IN YOUR
EXPERIENCE, THE MEDIA SEEMS TO
HAVE CHANGED DRASTICALLY SINCE
THE ELECTION OF DONALD TRUMP
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS, BUT
WASN'T ALWAYS THERE?
DO YOU THINK THE ATTITUDES WERE
SEEN TODAY WHERE THEY ARE IN THE
MEDIA COVERED UP, OR HAVE THEY
CHANGED?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THERE'S BEEN A TOTALITARIAN
INSTINCT ON THE RIGHT BECAUSE
IT'S KIND OF A RELIGIOUS FAITH.
SO THE INSTINCT HAS BEEN ANYBODY
WHO DISAGREES WITH ME IS EVIL.
JOURNALISM DEMANDED OPEN
DIALOGUE, HE HAD TO LISTEN TO
THE OTHER SIDE AND ALLOW THE
OTHER SIDE TO TALK, THAT IS WHAT
LIBERALISM WAS, THAT WAS THE
BASIC ENLIGHTENMENT VALUE IS YOU
HAVE TO ALLOW YOUR IDEAS TO BE
CHALLENGED AND YOU GET TO
CHALLENGE THE OTHER SIDE'S
IDEAS.
THAT EVAPORATED SLOWLY AND THEN
QUICKLY IT HAPPENED OVER TIME
AND THEN ALL AT ONCE AND YOU
WAKE UP IN THIS TOTALITARIAN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE NO ONE IS
ALLOWED TO TALK AND LEISURE
REPEATING A SMALL SET OF SLOGANS
AND THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF THE
BUSINESS, THE EDITORS, THE
PUBLISHERS COMMIT THE PEOPLE ON
TV NETWORKS, ARE ALL
PARTICIPATING IN IT.
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE 52 OF IMM IF
YOU'RE IN AGING AMERICAN, IT'S
TOTALLY SHOCKING TO WATCH.
>> I ALSO LOVED WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT MAKING IT QUICK AND DIRTY
WHEN YOU'RE WRITING.
I REMEMBER GETTING INTO GRAD
SCHOOL WHEN THEY SAID EVERY
COMMA  COULD BE A.
MAC.
YOU'VE HAD A LOT OF FASCINATING
PEOPLE, WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
INTERVIEW AGAIN IF THEY WOULD
TAKE YOUR CALL.
KK GOSH, THAT IS SUCH A GREAT
QUESTION.
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE.
I'D LOVE TO INTERVIEW ANYBODY IN
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP.
I'D LIKE TO INTERVIEW A
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN.
NO ONE WILL TALK TO ME.
NOBODY WILL COME ON THE SHOW.
YOU'RE A WHITE SUPREMACIST, WE
CAN'T TALK TO YOU.
REALLY, NO I'M NOT.
I JUST HAVE DIFFERENT IDEAS FROM
YOU, JUST COME ON AND TALK TO ME
LIKE A NORMAL HUMAN BEING.
WE TALK ALL THE TIME.
WE HAVE FOR A LONG TIME, WE
DISAGREE.
IT'S NOT THAT HARD, IT'S FUN.
TO GET MOST OF THE TIME IT IS
FUN, I WILL TALK TO MY PEOPLE
AND TRY TO GET YOU A
CONGRESSMAN.
>> TUCKER, I HAVE TO ADMIT I
WENT TO JOURNALISM SCHOOL SO IT
IS FASCINATING TO ME THAT YOU
ARE YOUR FIRST JOB OUT OF
COLLEGE WAS A FACT CHECKER, AND
I THINK FACT CHECKING HAS
CHANGED SO MUCH IN ADDITION TWO
TRADITIONAL JOURNALISM SO I WANT
TO GET YOUR TAKE ON THAT, BUT I
ALSO WANT TO KNOW WHERE WE CAN
BUY YOUR BOOK BECAUSE I KNOW YOU
HAVE A DIFFERENT STRATEGY.
>> FACT CHECKING USED TO REQUIRE
PEOPLE CALLING PEOPLE ON THE
PHONE AND ASKING THEM QUESTIONS
NOW IT REQUIRES GOING TO
WIKIPEDIA WHICH ISN'T A NEWS
SOURCE.
IT'S ANOTHER FORM OF PROPAGANDA,
THERE'S TRUTH ON THAT, BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY, IT'S NOT
RELIABLE.
SO THAT IS NOT FACT CHECKING.
THE BOOK IS ON TUCKER
CARLSON.COM.
IT'S AVAILABLE IN ALL KINDS OF
PLACES, BUT THE BOOK IS PARTLY
ABOUT THE CREEPING POWER OF THE
TECH MONOPOLIES, WHICH SQUELCH
HIS SPEECH, THOUGHTS, AND
FREEDOM, SO WHY NOT GO AROUND
THEM.
WE'RE TRYING A NEW VERSION OF
DISTRIBUTION HERE ON OUR
WEBSITE.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT WORKS.
WE NEED ALTERNATIVES TO WHAT WE
HAVE, I WOULD SAY THAT.
>> BEST OF LUCK.
>> TUCKER, CAN I ASK ONE MORE
QUESTION.
IS THERE ANYBODY THAT YOU'RE
READING NOW IN JOURNALISM THAT
YOU REALLY LIKE?
>> THERE ARE SO MANY ON SUB
STAFF, AND I PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
SAY BECAUSE SOME ARE LIKE
REFUGEES FROM THE LEFT AND I
DON'T WANT TO FURTHER DISCREDIT
THEM BY ADMITTING A READ THEM.
I GAVE UP MY NEW YORK TIMES AND
WASHINGTON POST SUBSCRIPTION
BECAUSE IT WAS JUST BORING.
OTHER THAN THAT I SPEND MY MONEY
ON SUB STACK AND I'M HAPPY ABOUT
IT.
>> THERE IS AN INTERESTING
WRITER'S OUT THERE NOW.
>> TUCKER, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HIS NEW BOOK, THE LON